so then um the next place we're going to
do a second last one
is what happens if i'm going to go back
to all of my original colors maybe you
want to do the same
so get your repeats out of the way
and put back all of the colors there we
go
now what if i want to arrange rather
than out of the n objects
all of them what if i only want to
arrange some of them and this is what i
reserved k for okay
so the way i'm going to phrase this
question is how many ways are there to
arrange
k objects
from n choices
so i've got my 10 this number as my
overarching theme
that's the number of things i can choose
from and then i only want k
of them right so let's go with say this
original 10
let's pick three of them okay let's just
make it nice and simple
so in the first spot i should say
how many spots are there well if i'm
just picking three instead of a
row of ten i'm going to have three boxes
right
one two three okay and um draw the boxes
draw them it might take you long
right and then you can actually put this
is part of your argument even if your
box looks like a trapezium like mine
in the first spot in the first spot how
many choices do i have
i still have ten right just like here i
still have ten
so then i pick one and then i say okay
i've got
the next spot to do so how many choices
are there now there's nine
and then there's eight okay so
you can see what's missing here is it's
got the 10 factorial
but there's what's missing off the end
yeah it's like the 10 factorial with the
seven factorial chopped off okay in fact
i like just for myself when i'm
explaining this to
other people i kind of like to say hey
there's actually bits
missing here right there's kind of like
a factorial that's not there
right um
and so on okay so in order to
get rid of this right this is 10
factorial
and i've got to divide through by this
so that it doesn't appear in the whole
10 factorial term right
so if i've got n choices i start whoops
wrong column
start with the n factorial which in our
case is 10
and i divide through by 7 factorial now
where does 7
factor in how does that number emerge
out of this
yeah so it's the 10 take away the three
that you've already got and that leaves
over however many
okay so i'm going to write n factorial
on
n minus k factor
okay which in our case over here that
was ten factorial on
seven factorial
which is really ten factorial on and
take away three factorial that's where
the numbers come from
okay all right now
i was so close this leads us to our last
and most important and kind of most
interesting result
which is to say this guy over here which
as we know
is given special notation what do we
call this
now this guy is super familiar right
super super familiar think back to the
start of this term
i think back to like the beginning of
last year that is almost exactly the
same as
nc well in this case k right which of
course is there's no coincidence that
you use such similar notation
um what is m c k or ncr or whatever
right um if i just go with decays
what's the difference between this and
that
yeah that's right so so all of these
pieces are still there it still has an n
factorial
it still has an n minus k factorial but
in addition to those
it's got this guy hanging on okay so
there's lots of ways to get to this
result
but i want to get to like what does this
mean in the context of all of this
i'm going to use these three pieces i'm
going to use all of them so think
carefully about what these mean
and i'm going to use them to generate
this result okay so you've got them down
your paper i need this space
unfortunately
so i'm going to
i can leave a while
okay so i'm gonna leave his dot point
hanging for a moment
and we'll come back to him let's start
from this because it was the closest to
what will get us to here okay let's
think about our um
we said we were going to pick out oh
that green is really similar to the
other
black there we go let's say we've got
that okay
so this is one of our arrangements right
this is one of our arrangements
now in our case here like the actual
numbers i've got
what would this be and the answer is
this
actual the numbers of this
for our example would be 10 factorial on
3 factorial 7 factorial yeah you got
you can see these guys always added to n
yeah so when i look at this
the three factorial which is extra bit
that's come in
how is that related to this idea here
and keep in mind it's on the denominator
right now the idea is that you've got
three
the three it corresponds to these guys
that i've just chosen
right now three factorial is how many
ways i have to arrange these guys
right so like for example this one and
then this one
and then this one and there's six that i
could do right in fact
there you go okay i'm happy with that
all right
so here are six arrangements
our three factorial arrangements of
these guys okay now hold on a second
have a look
um here we go this is what i'm thinking
about so i've got my 10 factorial
tell me why i divided by 7 factorial
tell me why go back it's on the board
why did i divide by 7 factorial
because i didn't count those ones i've
only got three
spots right so it's like hey there are
seven spots that actually aren't in this
situation
so i have divided by seven factorial
because i'm not even arranging them okay
that's good
and a three factorial that doesn't come
from like oh i've got a different number
of spots
it comes from the fact that hey there
are three factorial ways to arrange
these
but if i'm not arranging them with
respect to like what makes these
different
answer order makes them different right
they're all the same colors but i've put
them in different orders
okay if i say well if these are all the
same
right and just say look just arrange
them just put them in a heap
okay i don't care about which one is
first then which one is second and which
one is third
then all of these guys if i if i should
put them in a pile
they're all the same but they're all the
same so i have over
counted if i don't care about their
order does that make sense
so just like here right um no sorry this
one here when we were looking at
identical elements right
it's kind of treating these as identical
you can rearrange them and still get the
same
pile okay so here's our last
thing how many ways
now i can't see a range anymore i can't
say a range because i'm just putting
them in a
pile right and it's like look that pile
and that pile
and that pile all identical okay so
rather than using the word arrange
um i was avoiding the word before
because no one says
i can say either i've got two choices i
can say
choose right because a choice like one
two three
i'm still choosing the same three no
matter which way i turn them around
no matter which one of these i have i've
still chosen
the same three right so i'm gonna say
how many ways
um to choose
and underneath there underneath there i
want to put the same
kind of idea but different word you can
also say how many ways i did to combine
these three
right because if i were to
okay here you go and whatever order i
don't matter it doesn't matter i've
combined the same three
so they're really amount to the same
thing so how many ways are there to
choose and it's it's the same thing here
right it's still k objects three from
the n choices the ten right so how many
ways are there to choose k
objects and you may like to because
we've used the word choose already you
might like to say m
options right that's the way i have it
in my head anyway
okay so the way i get to this
is just like when i started with 10
factorial i'm going to say whoops i
overcounted
okay i'm going to start with mpk
because that's how many ways there are
to get these guys right so that's just
thinking about the three spots
so that's okay
but then i'm going to say hey this guy
has been overcounted quite a lot
by a factor of k factorial right look
three factorial in this case or four
factorial if i added another one on
okay so npk on k factorial
that of course is um n factorial on
n minus k factorial big set of brackets
all divided by k factorial you can see
this guy's gonna
sneak onto that denominator and that's
in
c k right